many parts of Western Europe and the US
are seeing a rise in coving 19 cases
thought to be driven by two new
sub-variants of the Omicron virus known
as ba4 and ba5 these Rises come
alongside the easing of safety measures
that were previously put in place to
curb the spread of the SARS covid II
virus testing being scaled back and
covid-19 booster vaccine take-up at
lower than expected levels ba4 and ba5
are Omicron viruses with a new
combination of mutations they were first
detected in South Africa earlier this
year and since then they have become the
dominant variants there
this has been the trend in other
countries the ba4 and ba5 subvariants
have spread to and the fact that they
have quickly become dominant over
previous sub-variants of Omicron would
indicate they Harbor mutations that make
them more transmissible this coming at a
time when there are waning levels of
protection from previously given
vaccines or previous infection
the two new subvariants are often
discussed together because the mutations
in their Spike protein Gene are
identical even though they differ in
mutations found Elsewhere on them the
spike protein Gene is key as this is
what the virus uses to infect and enter
human cells and changes here that make
the process easier and quicker will make
it more transmissible it is also the
part of the virus that is targeted by
the majority of covid-19 vaccines
both new variants carry an l452r
mutation thought to make the virus more
Contagious by enhancing the virus's
ability to attach to human cells and the
f486v mutation which may make it more
likely to evade previously garnered
protection so far there is no indication
that either subvariants are associated
with new symptoms or more severe disease
scientists are concerned that these new
subfariants are going to cause surges in
infections worldwide and put a strain on
Health Care Systems the best way to
protect yourself from these and other
variants of covid-19 is to get
vaccinated including getting the booster
vaccine ventilate indoor spaces and
where a high grade mask in appropriate
settings